Під час танення льодовиків
у басейні річки Прип'ять
утворилося величезне прильодовикове озеро.
Воно поступово наповнювалось
і в якийсь момент вода прорвала це озеро
і вилилася в долину Дніпра.
Це озеро витекло за кілька днів,
тобто це був абсолютно
катастрофічний паводок.
Вода текла настільки швидко і потужно,
що ці піски принесло до нас.
І якраз з проривом цього Прип'ятського
прильодовикового озера
і пов'язують появу тут пісків.
Повинен бути десь знак, так?
Не пам'ятаю, чи з того боку, чи із цього.
Справа буде, зараз побачу.
Коли військові пішли з полігону, залишилася
ділянка пісків площею 19,5 тисяч гектарів.
Це величезна ділянка.
І вже тоді природоохоронці стали порушувати
питання, що треба її заповідати.
Там були військові, доступ був обмежений,
ніхто особливо не знав, що там робиться.
А тут її відкрили і були спроби
заповідання декілька разів —
і Чорноморський заповідник,
і Інститут Зоології,
і ми, [Херсонський] державний
університет, намагалися заповісти.
Нічого не виходило.
Ми займалися створенням цього парку.
Свого часу професор Ходосовцев
керував цими роботами,
тобто у 2007–2008 роках
об'їхав усю цю територію,
склав детальний план,
підготував наукове обґрунтування.
І потім, до речі, коли вже створювали
парк, то теж виїжджав,
спілкувався з місцевим населенням,
переконував, щоб парк був.
На сьогодні це номер 2,
тобто ОП Олешківські піски 2020.09.09.
Це така методика для виміру
глибини в п'ятьох місцях.
Пісок тут буде 80 см завглибшки
у всіх п'яти випадках, я думаю.
А якщо це кам'янистий грунт,
то може бути 1 см, або 0, або 10 см.
До речі, в оцій нірці живе ємуранчик,
кандибка — кенгурушка, але маленька.
Ти розповідав, Івановичу, ні?
Нічого не розповідав?
У нас був проєкт по його дослідженню
разом зі спеціалістами Чорноморського
біосферного заповідника.
Вона тут живе — Stylodipus telum —
я навіть латиною вивчив,
хоча сам ліхенолог.
Він рухається як кенгуру, —
стрибає на задніх ногах,
а передні лапки зовсім маленькі.
Стрибає на кілька метрів і виходить з нірок
приблизно за десять хвилин до заходу сонця
і десь години дві активно бігає, живиться,
можна його побачити, а потім уже ховається.
Нори чистенькі тут, без нічого.
О, ось тут класно.
Протягом останніх п'яти років
ми описали один новий для науки рід.
Рід, названий на честь моєї доньки, яка
зібрала один із зразків, де був цей вид.
Вона у два з половиною роки повторювала
за батьком те, що він робив,
і щось накидала в пакетик.
Валявся на столі той пакетик, я подумав:
«Донька зібрала, треба подивитися».
А мені не вистачало ще одного зразка,
щоб описати новий для науки рід.
Відкриваю — а там він є.
Ну і назва його, Катерина Міцис Цетрарій,
пішла від сetraria aculeata, ось
цього лишайника, на якому він росте.
Він цікавий, його тут дуже багато.
Сetraria aculeata.
Коричневий, в нього такі маленькі
на кінчиках зігнуті щетинки,
завдяки яким його можна
навіть ось так прикріпити.
Що таке, наприклад, степ
і сільськогосподарське поле?
У степ ти можеш у будь-який час піти:
можеш там накосити сіна,
можеш випасати свою худобу,
зібрати лікарські рослини,
подихати чебрецевим повітрям.
А що таке поле?
На поле ти не можеш
піти у будь-який час, так?
Поки там, скажімо, росте пшениця?
Ти можеш взимку піти чи восени,
коли її вже скосили.
Тобто це територія з обмеженим доступом.
Зараз наші аграрії таку
кількість хімії ллють на поля,
що там немає комах, нема нічого.
Це отруєна територія з обмеженим доступом.
Що ви хотіли б, аби було
поряд з вашим місцем проживання?
Ще одне поле, яких навколо вистачає,
чи щоб усе-таки залишився клаптик степу?
Цікаво те, що ми з вами зараз у степу.
Насправді не в степу, а в степовій зоні,
а тут є дуже багато цікавих місць,
несхожих на степ.
І Буркути — це місце, яке не схоже на степ.
Завжди людина бачить природу і говорить:
«А це можна їсти?
А можна це дерево пиляти,
аби його спалити чи меблі зробити?"
Або їсти, або щось зробити.
Далі мозок людини не йде —
поїсти, та й все.
Насправді от ми дихаємо повітрям —
це екосистемна послуга.
Ми намагаємося просто сісти на кучугуру —
і десять хвилин ландшафтотерапії.
І ти вже трошки інакше почуваєшся.
Екосистемні послуги — це також послуги
від природи, які ми отримуємо, —
не тільки їсти, не тільки
пиляти дерева для меблів чи пічки.
Цю територію намагалися
розкрутити з погляду туризму,
але туристичні маршрути тут для гурманів.
Для тих, хто любить такі затишні місця,
куди ніхто не їздить, ліси, де мало людей,
але тут така, ще не туристична мекка,
і вона поки що має правильний баланс
між рекреацією та охороною.